i am with the emmy award-winning actor
sterling k brown from the hit series
this is us
thank you
okay you've been so very open will you
play a game with us to end the show
um of course i will
let's do it okay
it's called silent treatment which means
you get to mute if you want to on a
certain question you don't have to but
you do get one mute
if you want to give me the silent
treatment on a question are you ready
ready
okay
um i'm going to start easy i asked your
co-star uh milo ventimiglia um
what his favorite crayola color was what
his was forest green mine was periwinkle
what's yours
it's gonna be royal purple there's
something about that that just makes me
feel majestic yeah
okay what was the last lie you told
royal purple
um
okay have you ever woken up looked
around you and gone where am i
yes there's times in which you wake up
those times in which you wake up and
it's like between dusk and dawn and
you're not sure if you slept the whole
day or if you just slept so hard for an
hour that you can't even remember yeah
yeah that's tame
i'm like i've woken up a few places and
been like where am i and it was not like
oh i took a nap
i was like
how did i get here and
where am i all right what's your worst
habit that you just can't break
uh i will chew nails from time to time
but it's usually just one the pinky nail
on the left hand will get you that's
that's the one
is there it's weird it tastes better
it gets longer i let it grow longer than
any of the other ones because i like the
way it's shaped and then it gets so long
that i just want to milk
see these are the things i like knowing
about people i feel so much closer to
you now okay weirdest thing you've
googled lately
i was looking at marsupials the other
day because i've never been to australia
and i'm sort of fascinated with like
something living in a pouch for like
another several months after it's been
born and the pouch is it's not like a
cute pouch to be honest with you there's
a lot of
stuff
in there that i don't know marsupials
yeah sounds like my fanny pack okay um
and is this really the end of this is us
or do you think there will be a spin-off
i'm not gonna mute myself
there's always a possibility there's
always a possibility this is the end of
this show
right
but but you know you look at things like
cheers which had another great ending by
the way and then frasier had 12 seasons
after that you can never say never in
this business and so i'll i'll never say
never but i know the show is coming to
an end in terms of if it has any
offshoots
we shall see
thank you so much for gracing us with
your presence and talking about
survivorship today and you can go on the
drewbarmer show.com and get linked right
over there thank you for talking about
it and this is us is on nbc and we love
you thank you so much
i love you too drew thank you guys
[Music]